5 000
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fet
laissez la station de radio reprendre ses opérations normales
[Musique]
verre
votre
[Applaudissements]
parti non non non non non [
Rires]
non [
Musique]
[Rires]
pour quoi
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
ok
euh ok allons à l'avant du
bateau s'il te plait allons à l'
avant ici sur ta
gauche
tous toi R
la
[Musique]
ok ok ok
ok on reste à droite du
bateau donc c'est ok comme
ça très très lentement essaye  trop
petit,
c'est une radio LP, c'est la Garde côtière
[Applaudissements]
363 Garde côtière 3 6
Ladi monte la rampe ici sur le point de partir vers
la voiture co chip Lou, vous avancez votre
[Applaudissements]
ding Co côté 363 vents 030 équipage à 10
nœuds otim 29  ou 64 signalent le trafic
185 182 en provenance du sud,
estimant le temps d'arrivée dans 20 minutes pour
Resolute B,
ok, nous vérifions son SP 20 minutes pour
lever cette fois et nous
tournerons à gauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur Chear juste au-dessus du  ici
5500 hôtel après ok
nous
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois
à l'hôtel en dernier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
accessoire L'hôtel loer vérifie 182 avions
entrants estimant l'heure d'arrivée dans 19
[Applaudissements]
minutes et le numéro résolu 182 Victor
Echo est à 25 miles
au sud-ouest
estimation euh résolu dans  14
minutes novembre 182 Victoire Echo radio
vent 0203 à 15
noeuds
62 trafic
hélicoptère vers la station sud-ouest
hélicoptère B 206 dep
offb question à 16 milles de repos Lo Bay
à cette
heure et Victor Echo
[Applaudissements]
chanceux ok maintenant on descend si tu as
la fois on redescend très bas à l'
avant du bateau tu as le temps ou ouais
ok on descend on descend très bas à l'
avant du
bateau
ok
[Musique]
lcraft inbound Sy
182 toujours environ 14
out non
quand il rentre  dans
[Musique]
la
ok tournez à gauche on va
très bas devant le
bateau
[Musique]
Radio aéroport Resolute
ok monsieur Che vient d'arriver à 8 5  gmoi
et euh nous parlons à un navire, nous allons
atterrir momentanément avec lui euh merci
pour votre aide aujourd'hui et euh s'il vous plaît
remerciez l'autre gars et nous vous parlerons
[Applaudissements]
plus tard 363
[Musique]
radio
[Musique  ]
avant, d'accord à cause de l'
Ombre, nous
[Musique]
avons obtenu
182 pour le
point de départ
et deux Victor EO sont maintenant à 5 miles de
Resolute à
4 500 actuellement sur le côté nord-ouest
de
[Musique]
Griffin 182
[Applaudissements]
victoire en ce moment
affirmative  Point de
[Musique]
Départ passer à
gauche
descendre
c'est
l'hélicoptère où
attendre
peut monter un peu monter monter monter monter monter monter
dessus depuis le
haut ok on le suit
désolé on est tout en
bas on peut en prendre  vitesse si vous
ne voulez pas de
problème
Resolute Novembre 182 Victor rapport
miles Piste
35 novembre 182 Victory Echo WIS 360
équipage à 15
KN
292 L'état de la surface de la piste
17352 est 100 % nue et sèche à l'heure de
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
2201 combien de temps  le temps qu'on puisse voler euh on est sur le
point de l'appeler ici
maintenant
non
[Musique]
SC [
Musique]
réponds
[Musique]
gaz [
Musique]
toi
[Rires]
Resolute Novembre 182 Victor Echo report
[Musique]
m vict e gagne 1 0 à 10 heures
[Applaudissements]
15 Je pense qu'on va voler jusqu'à pour
prendre du carburant Voler 2 heures et on termine
la journée je pense que donc on n'a pas besoin d'
aller trop loin ça va être  pareil je vais
très loin ça va être pareil ici pareil
ouais juste
couper couper du
beurre ok droite monter avant je veux
Tob
[Musique]
Maxim
sur ton
ok peut weay comme ça pour transmettre
[Musique]
[Rires]
[  Musique]
la
[Musique]
Resolute
bember final
35 twole wi 0302 à 10
[Musique]
15 [
Musique]
[Musique]
c'est à peu près ça
pour ça
oh non d'accord allons-y
comme bien ok vas-y
ok bien allons-y on fait le plein on y va encore
et après
Terminez merci beaucoup
[Musique]
continuez, vous pouvez voir la ligne s'il vous plaît
avant
[Applaudissements]
Je ne comprends pas avant de
parler étranger
[Rires]
je
vais juste à F ceci
[Musique]
tout
le monde
parle
pour un
discours
étranger
[Musique]
le discours a
été repris,
je dis p
un peu
[Musique]
oh ouais [
Musique] d'accord
un petit
peu, d'accord, tout
[Musique]
d'accord [
Musique]
pour
B mais la porte arrière
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Rires  ]
on passe on passe
ok à l'arrière du bateau
ok
cette tarte
ne fais pas oh
vitesse ok 15 n
[Musique]
comme
lentement lentement peux-tu rester ici comme ça
non non
[Musique]
[Rires]
[  Rires]
[Musique]
non
terminé
[Musique] [
Musique]
avant [Musique]
pour
[Rires]
pour [
Musique] [
Rires] [
Rires]
avant
[Musique]
ok, c'est vrai,
le bo
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
[  Rires]
pour
[Rires]
pour ne pas faire
comme
[Rires]
à gauche à
droite [
Musique]
avant
[Rires] [
Musique]
[Rires]
[Musique]
spe
[Rires]
PA avant avant
B donc